hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
evaluating the kidney chip for
transporter-mediated
drug drug interactions applications
i'm alexis krauss of labyrinth and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labberts and sponsored
by amulet
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
amuletbio.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenters
dr steven anderson
senior vice president at lab corporation
of america holdings
and chief scientific officer at covents
dr kian jin jiang vice president of
technology implementation
and field science at emulate and dr
donald mckenzie
vice president head of global metabolism
for a complete biography on all of our
presenters please visit the biography
tab
at the top of your screen dr anderson
you may now begin your presentation
thank you for that introduction hi i'm
steve anderson i'm the chief scientific
officer for covants uh and welcome to
our webinar this afternoon i'm joined
by colleagues from emulate and covants
for us to review with you a very
collaborative
project advancing organ on a chip
technology to look at applications for
drug drug
interactions uh transporter-mediated
drug drug interactions
with a kidney chip
so what we'll be reviewing today
are i'll give an overview of the need
for
better pre-clinical models in the area
of drug development
i will focus on that with regard to a
renal chip i'll hand it over to
our colleague kj to talk about
the development of a proximal tobial
kidney chip
on the emanate emulate platform and then
she'll hand it over to
don to talk about um
our assessment of the functionality of
that
uh renal chip looking at morphology
expression of key biomarkers and
transporters
the assessment of the function of those
transporters
and then evaluation of drug drug
interactions
so for pre-clinical models which are
essential in the drug development
process
they provide a variety of challenges one
of the challenges
is the predictability of those models
and the lack of predictability which
leads to
a significant attrition during the drug
development process
those models have gaps in the ability to
address safety concerns of new molecules
as well as mechanism of action and
potential efficacy
the assessment of safety or toxicity of
a new asset
in preclinical models is
impacted by a variety of factors the
complexity
the fact that there are multiple
contributing factors
the role of multiple cell types in
the expression of that toxicity and very
critically
the fact that there are species
differences as you try
to translate data from an animal species
into what you might expect in humans
one attempt to try to bridge that gap is
is to look at other pre-clinical or
non-uh clinical models
and cell-based models these include
in vitro models and also in silicon
models that take
computer assessment of potential
uh interactions that would occur within
humans to try to understand and better
uh have better predictability
animal models which are really the
staple
in drug development have a number of
uh challenges and and features that are
relevant in the process one as we've
talked about is the translatability of
data from animals into humans
due to species differences another is
overall cost so there's great interest
in in vitro models human cell based
models
to try to address that variety of
potential uses
again in candidate molecule screening
that's been something that's been used
for a long time
to do mechanism of action studies and
then also to look at
that translation from
pre-clinical into clinical
the challenges that still exist in these
systems
is is there a physiological equivalence
from a cell-based model to an organism
expression of that toxicity or that
parameter
the other is we're dealing with single
cells most often so can we translate
this
into a whole system so again they also
provide
challenges
we'll try to address some of those today
but there are a variety of cell-based
model
models that are have been utilized in
drug development
everything from traditional
two-dimensional cell cultures
3d cell cultures bio-printed cells
organoids today we'll talk about the
development of
an organoid chip modality
multiple organs on a chip and even in
the cancer space
tumor spheroids to try to really
understand
things in cancer like tumor
heterogeneity
the potential advantages of these
systems
are reduction in cost potential
efficacy in the timing of that
assessment
and then the decreased use of animal
models
in the pre-clinical space
there are opportunities to improve these
uh models
uh one is the incorporation of
biomarkers you'll see a little bit of
that today
the lever the ability to leverage or
combine
models and then improvements in models
and today we'll focus on some of those
improvements
leveraging the organ on a chip
technology
there's a number of applications that
really are in front of us today and on
the horizon
for such models first of all is the
optimization of candidate selection
again being a more holistic look
we are always interested in reducing the
dependence on animal models and
redistributing those
resources elsewhere so they fit well
within the 3r approaches
that are very much of
a focus within the industry there are
applications potentially where systems
are currently inadequate
the model that we'll talk about today
fits very well into that
and then the opportunity to integrate
both pharmacological and toxicology
studies
again providing some of these of
examples of that
in the discussion today
the relevance for a advanced model
in kidney or remo functionality
is highlighted in this slide there's a
number of uh
interesting publication and guidance
around assessing drug drug interactions
and in the middle the gray two bubbles
highlights some of the current gaps that
exist today
we'll talk about those in greater detail
as we review
the development of this proximal
tubule kidney chip and its application
but
many of those include the uh the ability
to translate that
in vitro model uh that in vitro system
into something that allows to look at
drugs transporter
and drug drug interaction and then also
the ability to take that data
and model it in a way that makes sense
as you move from an in vitro model
into an in vivo situation
so with that i'm going to turn it over
to kj
who will start to talk and provide
details
on the development of the organ
ownership technology
so kj over to you
thank you so much steve uh for the a
great overview
so uh from here i will highlight how
organs and chips can recreate the
complex cellular micro environment
by combining different key components
so within the organ chip we can build
tissue tissue interface
by establishing epithelium and
endothelium layers
on each channel and the porous membrane
which can be coated with extracellular
metrics
allows the cells to communicate a key
features
of our organ chip is the ability to
create
dynamic environment by applying
different degrees of flow
or mechanical forces and not only that
we can build additional complexity by
adding circulating immune cells within
flow
or a stromal compartment or interstitium
by utilizing ecm layer and stromer cells
inside
we can also add pathogenic or commands
and microbes
on the tissue layer and we can even
create hypoxic system
to provide more in vivo relevant micro
environment
within the chip so all of this
is designed to build organs and chips to
be used for various applications
including
compound efficacy safety
pharmacokinetics
and mechanistic investigation
first let's take a look how we can build
a human proximal tubule in our chip
emulate organ chips are made of flexible
uh transparent polymer that has two
independent microfluidic chainers
separated by a porous membrane we can
culture the proximal tubular epithelial
cells in the top chainer
and bring our endothelial cells in the
bottom channel
then we can apply fluid flow
independently in both
channels to create a dynamic environment
like within our kidney
so the porous membrane allowing
molecular transport
and fluid flow in both channels are
critical components
to recreate physiological development
within our environment
in our chip and to give you a sense of
scale
the surface of the cultural area in the
chip
is approximately 70 percent of one
wealth
of the 96 well plate
now uh let's take a look how we apply
flow
within our chip and pot
so after establishing the tissue culture
within the chips
they're connected to this unit are
called a pot
the pot contains inlet and outlet
reservoirs for both top and bottom
channels
once we start the flow in our automated
cultural instrument
the media from the pod inlet reservoirs
enters
the respective trainer in the chip
travels across
the channel and then collects in the
outlet reservoir
and we are not showing our instrument
here but it is a pressure driven
unidirectional flow system without any
tubings and syringes
then these schematic views show how the
volume changes from inlet to outlet over
time
you can add up to 4.5 ml of culture or
dosing media in each inlet when you
start
then you can set a flow rate from zero
to thousand
microliter per hour in our instrument
so at time two on the right you have
increased volume in the outlet
reservoirs over time
so for the kidney chip we apply 60
microliter per hour of flow rate
and the effluent sample can be collected
at any time during the culture
if you collect daily you have around 1.4
ml
of effluent from each channel for the
kidney chip
and you can run different types of
biochemical analysis
or a major parent compound or a
metabolic concentration
directly from this eggplant
also cells from each channel can be
harvested
lysed or stained directly in the chip
once the experiment is finished
and now you will see examples of
transcriptomics and staining data later
then let's take a closer look inside of
the chip
when we add dosing solution through the
pot
so here uh we we can add the compound
either
to the top or bottom channel to run our
top to bottom or from the top type of
transport study
across the cell layers underflow also
multiple compounds can be added
sequentially or simultaneously
based on your experimental design also
not only small molecules but for example
biologics
viruses immune cells or other types of
components can be added in a similar way
and you can measure not only a transport
across the cell layer
but also complex cellular interaction or
responses from the cells
in the chip
for the drug transporter study we first
checked
non-specific binding or obstruction
level of the compounds to the chip
material as you can see the key points
that we summarize
on the top right compounds that are
substrates of
active transport in the kidney tend to
be hydrophilic
which generally corresponds to a minimum
compound loss due to silicon-based
material absorption and this is shown
in the reference on the left regarding
the extended clearance classification
system
so when we tested the material
absorption of the probe substrates that
we use
for the drug transport studies as you
can see on the bottom right
recovers compound concentration
inductive effluent
which were normalized by the
contradicting media
showed no absorption for all substrates
into the chip material
as we are expected has any compound
shown a tendency of absorption
we have a means to measure it and
proactively understand
and adjust for any potential impact
through a simple kit
specifically a design for this purpose
now uh let's take a look at a specific
example of the impact of flow
this is the data from red collecting dr
kidney chip
a different region of the nephron that i
studied 10 years ago while developing
these organ chips
so under static condition you can see
dense actin fibers covering the entire
cytoplasm
however once we start the flow you see a
significant change
within just a few hours rearrangement of
the cytoskeletal structure
especially accumulation of actin
filaments
at a peripheral cell borders and there
are other
similar reports on the proximal tubule
cells as well
so this structural change and flow
further contribute
to correct localization of transporters
to epica
or vasoletto membranes and this example
clearly demonstrates
the importance of flow for maintaining a
more physiologically relevant
renal culture system in vitro
then let's take a look how emulate team
has optimized the human proximal tubule
kidney chip
as part of our collaboration with covens
the proximal tubule is where glomerulous
filtrates
first pass through and this is highly
specialized reason for various molecules
reabsorption and excretion
between the tubular lumen and
peritubular capillary
so for the model optimization generally
critical components that we focus are
good quality
of the cell piece relevant ecm proper
seating density and order between epi
and endo
media and flow rate and you can see on
the
right table some key information from
the snapshot
of our protocol after intensive
optimization work
with broader ranges of experimental
parameters
for each component and we have a full
protocol
of this model available one note
regarding the stretch
while this is beneficial uh to improve
functionality of some of organ models
including
alveolus intestine or glomerulus
this was not necessary for the proximal
tubule
based on our comparison study all year
so we only apply flow
that stretch for this model and we have
published it on a globalized chip
model as well
here are some example images of the
characteristic morphology
of the proxima tubular epithelia and
renal endothelial cells
within the proximal tubule kidney chip
you can see monolayers of both cells
maintained
throughout the culture underflow in the
chip
and you can monitor this type of
dermatology
under the bright field microscope any
time during your culture
and these both cells are kidney specific
human primary cells
especially culture with green
endothelial cells is important
in the kidney both glomerular and
peritubular capillary endos are
fenestrated
allowing molecular transport and
the one that we are using also
commercially available sources of renai
and
cellular cells are from google metals
we can also stain and image specific
markers of both
epithelial and endothelial cells
directly in the chip
using standard fluorescent microscopes
including confocal
and high content imager we can label the
primary cilia
by immunophysics and staining of
acetylated tubulin
or a scanning electron microscope and
from that
you can also see our brush borders in
the proximal tubular epithelial cell
we also checked other markers including
adherence junction protein
beta-catenin and thai junction protein
occluding
water channel protein aquaporin 1 and
sodium
potassium pump or indicating correct
localization of these markers and uh for
the arena endothelial cells in the
bottom channel
we confirmed the expression of the key
endothelial cell markers
including cd31 piccam1 and vgr
category so from all of the
characterization data
and numerous studies that we have
performed within the proximal tubule
or kidney chip we are confident that we
have established
a viable functional and dynamic
human kidney model in our chip so with
that
i will hand over the presentation to don
to provide details on the transporters
and ddi studies using this chip thank
you
great thank you kj really appreciate it
again thank you everybody for for taking
the time out of your day
to attend the webinar so when we entered
into the collaboration with
emulate one of the goals that we had was
was to establish the list of
requirements that are going to be needed
to
to generate a translatable model to fill
that gap that steve mentioned
towards the beginning of the talk i
think over the last few slides you saw
that
emulate has done an outstanding job with
the engineering in really replicating
the renal flow
that you would see within a
physiological system as well as then the
interaction of both the vascular
as well as the proximal tubule cells and
this
was shown to actually result in
appropriate membrane polarization which
is critical for the appropriate
disposition of the transporters on
either the apical or basolateral side
of the cells so moving forward we wanted
to make
certain that we were seeing the
appropriate expression of the relevant
transporters
that are of interest to pharmaceutical
companies in terms of research and
development
as well as regulatory bodies in terms of
both the elimination of molecules
as well as then the potential for drug
drain interactions
make certain that the coordinated
membrane disposition
is actually translating to the
activities that we would expect
and then from there make certain that we
have not only measurable
activities from a messenger but but
functional activity
of of the various transporters against
target molecules
and then that would translate into the
expected inhibition profiles that we
would see
in order to generate the adequate
clinical
drug drug interaction models
so we ask ourselves why is it important
why do we need an advanced renal model
as opposed to a number of the
technologies that we have available
to us today and the simple answer is
that we know that
sesame compounds will interact with with
multiple transport
systems as they're progressing through
the kidney or in particular here the
proximal tubule
using metformin as an example here of
the interactions with oct2
as well as then mate 1 and may 2k and
it's the interaction
of various compounds with those
transporters that would result in the
potential for a drug drug interaction
this is many of the systems that we have
today are singly expressing
or don't necessarily fully represent the
tissue
so it can be difficult to model outcomes
when you do see these combination of
effects coming through so one of the
major things that we needed to do first
and foremost was to ensure
that we have appropriately expressed
transporters without within the system
and what we're showing here
is the the relevant transcriptomic data
looking at both
the kidney chip model as well as then
those from a
a transwell system that was generated
with the same cells
and what we can see is that the the chip
model
actually maintains the differentiation
that you would expect to see as well in
in a relevant human model
with the continued expression of all of
the relevant transporters
yes in some instances they are up
regulated but but the thing that we need
to remember is that within the human
kidney that this is actually looking
across four different donors
um in terms of the data there so many
instances this is actually within what
we would expect in terms of the standard
deviation
and taking that forward
and this in and of itself translates
very very well
in terms of the activity that we see
within the systems
so within the trans well system that we
described in the last cell
and the last slide what we see is that
there is continues to be
the the action of pgp particularly
around
the active transport of digoxin and we
do
see an e-flux ratio greater than two
which is what we would use as our
standard
in terms of of accounting for it for
active efflux
however when we start looking at the
other other relevant transporters
oct2 mate 1 may 2k as well as oat 1
we're not really seeing that
differentiation come through over time
so the e flux ratio stays right around
that one
we never make it to that that level of 2
which would be required in order to
show an active model that that we would
basically use to take forward to say
that there is an interaction going there
however that changes when we move
forward to the chip based model
so again showing the the exact same
compounds here
excuse me digoxin for pgp metformin for
the mates as well as then oct2 activity
so when we look at the those
transporters expressed on the apical
membrane
we see a much greater efflux ratio for
pgp
as compared to the transwell membrane as
well as the metformin
basically showing the activity that one
would expect there
again just meeting that threshold of two
on day eight
but then exceeding it on day 14 showing
us good active transport within the
system
the same can be said for those
transporters that are expressed on the
basal lateral membrane
so looking at pah are the pair amino
hippie rate
as well as the tea tetra ethyl ammonium
for oat 1 as well as oct2
so again on both day 8 and day 14
we are seeing an efflux ratio greater
than 2 and that is maintained
throughout the system likewise we
do have additional data that's not
presented within this presentation
for a defover sephardine as well as
valsartan
showing the broader range of activity
across a number of different molecules
so while activity in and of itself is
great
it's really the first step it's really
the the initial step
that we wanted to to accomplish
what this really comes down to though is
whether or not we're able to show
a strong assessment of the drug
transporter interactions
and again we set these experiments up
looking at
compounds that that are mentioned that
are appropriate within the
the guidelines that are presented by the
various regulatory bodies
as well as then looking to to set this
up in a
physiological manner so the experimental
setups um
the victim drug was administered to
either the apical or the basal lateral
side
of the chip so that we could basically
look at the differential
efflux ratios there the inhibitor was
infused through both the apical as well
as the basal lateral channel
this is to replicate what we would see
with the the inhibitor
or the perpetrator that would be present
in the bloodstream on the basal lateral
side
as well as then what could be present on
the apical side entering the proximal
tubule
through just standard gfr
the p apparent was determined at
multiple concentrations of the inhibitor
and then plotted in order to determine
the ic50
and in this case because of the
concentrations that we're utilizing
the ic50 can be used as a rough marker
for
the the ki within the experiments
so the specific data that i'm showing
here is the
interaction against pgp for digoxin
and quinidine with digoxin of course
as the victim drug and quinidine as the
perpetrator
as you see here what we can see
is over the course of increasing
concentrations of quinidine
we can actually see the efflux if you
will
normalize out so that in terms of the
efflux ratio
we're actually seeing a very strong
concentration dependent
inhibition going forward with an ic50 in
this case
of 0.723 micromolar that's determined
over the course of the experiment
this is then replicated i should say or
enhanced
um through through the assessment of a
number of different
drug interactions so in this case here
our victim tea
perpetrator cymetidine as well as then
cymenidine against metformin
looking at pah for proprenocid and then
provenance it again against
a depovir and in every instance again
we can see a very dramatic and very
clear-cut
concentration dependent interaction
throughout the system
with the ic50s reported there for
both pgp as well as in looking at the
oct1 versus mates
oct2 inmates as well as then the organic
anion transporters as well with pro
benefit acting as the perpetrator
but what this really comes down to is
what is our ability
to model the data so a lot of the the
inhibition experiments that i was
showing previously
could frankly be replicated in some of
the single transporter
expressing models but where those models
tend to fall apart
is that when we start trying to develop
clearance predictions
from a proximal tubule so we took the
data
that was generated here and and we
generated
models to actually look at what those
clearance predictions are
and then from there taking that into a
model for drug inhibition
and then the potential changes of the
auc
so the upper limit in terms of the
modeling experiments was calculated as
the summation of the clearance
from the glomerular filtration as well
as the proximal tubal secretion
assuming negligible distal tubular
reabsorption
because as we think about the totality
of renal clearance it is a combination
of all of those systems
the proximal tubule secretion clearance
was calculated from the the tubule
kindle chip model
in the flux ratio i'm assuming active
for passive transport equilibrium
equilibrium excuse me achieved between
the the gfr
as well as then the proximal tillial
blood supply in vivo
distal tubular reabsorption that was
assessed assuming equilibrium
achieved between the unionized compound
and the proximal tubule
and the unionized unbound fraction of
the proximal
tubule blood supply in viva
so as we look at this we need to
remember
that the distal tubular reabsorption is
different between the different
compounds so
dedox digoxin excuse me while we do see
active transport
of pgp and the proximal tubule there is
significant
reabsorption that occurs within the
distal tubule
and that is reflected in the model that
we have here or the actual in vitro
uh predicted clearances versus the
actual that are seen in a clinical
environment
so not only are we looking then at the
the kidney chip values but then also
looking and comparing that to the
transwell
values and what we can see is that in
many times
the proximal tubule kidney chip predicts
the clearance value
of only 85 percent or 85 percent of the
clinical value for a defiber
63 for metformin and 72 for phs
pha excuse me that says compared to the
trans well
uh models which in many instances are
under predicting that clearance
and yielding if you will differential
results as compared to what would one
would expect
to achieve in a clinical environment and
hence the gap that we see
between the the transwell with the
current models
and the clinical trials that are then
required as part of the drug interaction
guidance documents
so from there we needed to extrapolate
this data
and really explore the potential of the
model or the application of the model
to translate and really show that drug
drug interaction
and compare that to a clinical setting
so
again the mathematical model set up
using single compartment
pk elimination model basically just
within the renal
and using inputs of dosing regimen from
published clinical trials
in terms of the kidney transport or drug
drug interactions
as well and then utilizing the outputs
comparing the predicted clinical impact
to clearance
and area under the curve and comparing
that to reported clinical values
so again focusing on the the first
example there
of the digoxin quinine model
again looking at the jackson or the big
victim
basically a single iv dose at one
milligram
quinidine is the perpetrator 200
milligrams orderly four times a day
and again the population of healthy
volunteers
the clinical trial um across four
different
replicates showed an average total
clearance decrease of about 46 percent
across the two um and within the kidney
trip production we're actually seeing an
intrinsic secretion clearance decrease
of 67 percent
however then when we bring in the
totality of their total
renal clearance that matches that which
we saw in clinical state again of 46
this in and of itself translated very
well
to what we would expect to see in terms
of of the change in auc
as predicted so with digoxin given the
clearance and half-life the compound we
do see in a normal setting complete
clearance within a 24-hour period
however because we're inhibiting that in
the presence of quinidine
we do see accumulation within the clinic
and that is modeled
very very well within this experiment
here
so excuse me the kidney chip prediction
basically sees a 59 decrease in digoxin
clearance
the clinical study uh basically showing
approximately 54
so again very very well predicted there
likewise
too what it comes down to is the overall
change in exposure
seeing 108 28 increase in digoxin auc
with the kidney chip prediction compared
to 166 percent increase
with digoxin exposure in the clinical
trial
something that would not be accounted
for or seen within a trans well model
this in turn is also replicated through
the other transporter
interactions that we would expect to see
so as previously talked about with pgp
with
quinidine and jidoxin we do the same
with submetadine
and metformin as well as then probenacid
and the defophere
again with us metformin we would expect
to see
a re reduction in renal clearance of
about 27
the predicted clinical impact from the
the renal chip model
is a 20 to 38 percent reduction in renal
clearance
likewise an auc increase of metformin in
the clinic is observed approximately 50
percent
with the the chip model again being
within twofold
of the 26 to 60 percent increase in
in auct when we look at the depth of
fear
as a victim drug again we would expect
to see there
an increase at least what we saw within
the clinical
publications is an increase of aec of
approximately 82 percent
which again is is well modeled with an
auc
from the chip model an increase there of
64
as a result of a 39 overall reduction
in renal clearance
so as we look at this chip it really
provides
that bridge that we're looking for in
terms of the need for an advanced renal
model
the current static systems are good for
determining whether a compound is a
substrate or inhibitor of a transporter
we can determine ki values but what
they're missing
is the interaction of the transport
systems
the chip as we've demonstrated
throughout the course of the talk
does express the multiple transporters
that one would see within the proximal
tubule
and those the interaction of those
transporters are well modeled
in terms of translating the data to
clinical outcomes
so we're no longer jumping from a static
model
that gives us limited in vitro data
straight to a clinical trial
there's something that's in between that
fills that gap
which is the proximal tubule chip that
has been well engineered by emulate
and that we're utilizing a covants in
order to to generate
relevant data so again to summarize
what emulate has been able to generate
is a very well engineered chip
a very well engineered system that is
easy to use
that emulates the proximal tubule
that one would see in a fish in a
physiological system
renal flow is replicated which allows
the the system to actually behave
very similar to what one would see in
the physiologic
physiology of an individual we do see
the interaction between the renal
vascular and the renal tubule
endothelial and epithelial cells as
those move forward
likewise with the appropriate membrane
polarization
as well as the expression of the various
transporters we are seeing the
deposition
as appropriate to both the apical as
well as in the basal lateral side
of the cells but most
importantly these are all coming
together to give us measurable activity
as well as then the appropriate
inhibition profiles that we would expect
to see
and all of this comes together to be
able to translate into relative clinical
outcomes
that can be utilized to better predict
what could be happening
within a patient as a compound is moving
forward
so with that i'd like to acknowledge the
teams that both emulate as well as at
covants that are responsible for
for the generation as well as in the
modeling
of this data so josiah i'm responsible
for
for the modeling ananta uh responsible
for
for much of the actual in vitro data
that we're seeing and the teams moving
that forward
so with that we'd be very very happy to
to take any questions that you have
and again thank you very much for for
taking the time to
out of your day to spend with us
thank you dr anderson dr zhang and dr
mckenzie for your informative
presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first
question is how long do epithelial
cells remain active and over a period of
time do they change
physiology or biochemical properties
i will take the uh this question this is
kj um
yes um based on our snapshot that i
presented
uh we could go usually up to 14 days
in culture total uh based on our
characterization morphology data
we think that window allow really do
multiple different types of functional
states
and other viability and different
applications including toxicity
transporter studies
and over time what we noticed was
morphologically
proliferation rate became a little bit
uh
over so um that's the
kind of optimal window that we could
propose and
we can see a little decline on after
14 days in culture
wonderful thank you so much for that
answer kj so we'll move on to our next
question which is
do you see any expression or morphology
changes in the 3d kidney model
with mechanical stress
yeah so go ahead kj yeah
i'll take question uh so based on uh key
uh transporters or keep protein
expression
based on immunofluorescent staining or
western blood to check protein level
and gene expression level as well we
could see our improvement
overall expression level and also
correct localization when we compare the
chip under the flow versus aesthetic
condition
also based on our comfort z section
image
with the epica and bezel electromarker
staining
we could also notice that increased cell
height
under the flow in the chip compared to
the static culture which show
very a flat uh cell structure
thanks aj and if i can add as well so we
also did look
at the various experiments
initially under flow rates to optimize
the flow rate and we did see
dual differential transporter
interaction
and the ability if you will to for for
reabsorption
um with with the the flow rate so that
has been optimized within the chip
wonderful thank you so much for that so
our next question
have you done any site-to-site
comparison for this model
if yes how was the variability
yeah i will provide the answer first
so we did a comparison study especially
between
emulate uh versus kuvin's site
uh last year uh when we were ready to
transfer the technology
uh we measured some of the subfleets
that we presented today
based on some influx ratio that we could
see
which was measured by uh lcms um
from immunolysite and then radiolabel
substrate uh from carbon side
we could see tight variability it was
within
10 or 20 percent variability initially
and then uh from there what kuben's team
did was
uh further really tweaking optimizing
the condition
to improve uh even better overall influx
ratio and functionality
so based on initial comparison we could
see quite a tight
variability between side to side
wonderful thank you so much so our next
question um
is anti-body effect could that be
monitored
using this emulate chip
yeah so this is done i'll take that one
so yeah so with the
with the push towards large molecules
within the industry right now we do
believe that this model
could be looked at to to gauge the
the interaction of antibodies on the
basal lateral side
um so the antibody and circulation the
other advantage is not only would we be
able to look
at just a straight antibody but we could
also apply it to
other types of therapies like antibody
drug conjugates
nucleotide therapies and the like and
for instance with an adc we'd be able to
look at
the antibody itself the small molecule
warhead
by itself as well as then the conjugate
great we want to remind our audience
that any questions that we
didn't have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by speakers via the
email address that you provided
at the time of registration so let's
move on to
our next one if these
uh has this data been published and if
yes
is there um is there any references for
more detailed reading
listen i'll take that one as well so the
manuscript
is currently in progress um in terms of
coming together
the the plan was for us to initially
uh present this at issx as well as then
with the webinar but
we do expect the the publication to be
coming out in the in the near future
thank you so much for that clarification
so our next
question have you tested different flow
rates
in the kidney chip or excuse me um
what types of additional applications
can we do
using the kidney proximal tubule chip
so mr donaghy there are a number of
different uh
things that we're looking at uh
particularly with the uh
the second horizon of the project beyond
just the drug drug interactions but
taking it back to that is is the
potential to use this
to to assess nepal toxicity
uh based on the drug drug interaction
where for example
you could see active uptake on the the
basal lateral side
but then prevent the efflux into
the apical side causing a concentration
effect within the
proximal tubule cells themselves
resulting in nephrotoxicity
i also know that our colleagues at
emulator are also looking at a couple
applications so kj if you want to
yeah sure yeah yeah so additionally we
can do the disease
modeling um we can we can kind of induce
injury status uh for example treating tj
better
for example and then we can also utilize
patient-drive
cells in the chip as well to model this
certain disease
including uh acute kidney injury uh
models
and then we can do some therapeutic
testing for advocacy
perspective also uh we can do copy 19
relate to research as well
um there are multiple cell types
expressing
ac2 for example including prototype
messenger cell and proxima tubule cell
as well so
kitten cell highly affected by copy 19
are causing
acute kids and injuries so those type of
applications are also available
thank you so much for the clarification
from both of you so
our next question is there there's a
couple parts to this next question
so the first part does the inhibition of
digoxin by quinodine in the model
suggest
the ddi occurred in the proximal tubule
now do we have clinical or pre-clinical
evidence
to support this and the last part of the
question
can the model used for predicting
digoxin absorption
ddi as an alternative of coco 2
of yes
so thanks alexis so
in this case we are showing if you will
the the
inhibition of digoxin or pgp
might be a better way to put it in the
proximal tubule
and then using the computational model
for the overall impact from the distal
tubule
in terms of the
substitute for for caico 2 i would argue
that
we're looking at a very different system
with the
the intestinal and likewise the the
current
hypothesis current theory is that pgp
eflux really doesn't impact overall
absorption
um in a significant matter um
but with that said i we also do know
that there is
an intestinal chip under development and
you know some technology if you will
linking up the the organ
system to better emulate what's going on
with that system
is is better than trying to substitute
one organ system for another
kg i don't know if you have anything
else you wanted to add
yeah that was that's good thank you dan
wonderful so we still have time for a
couple couple more questions but again
as a reminder any questions that we
don't get to today or those submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information that you
provided
at the time of registration so our next
question is oh
let's look for one okay how about this
one
was 60 microliters an hour the optimized
flow rate
yeah i can take this question uh the
answer is yes
we test a different flow rate including
60
and then when we tested different flow
rate what we found very interesting was
compared to static we could see clear
differences in terms of uh
transcriptomic
uh global gene expression profile also
functionality however
among different flow rate groups we
didn't see
that major differences so based on
transcriptomic expression data also
functionality data is flux ratio
we haven't seen any big major
differences
so 16 microliter i was based on that
testing optimized flow rate that we are
applying
thank you kj for that answer so our next
one
in terms of drug screening what is the
rate of throughput
so this is done i'll take this one so
this
this model right now really is not
designed for
early screening the the
theory in the way that we're looking at
it is the the singularly expressed
models
do a very good job and are a good
initial
start if you will in terms of the
experimental processes for compounds
moving through the system
where we see this model really fitting
in is that that gap
between excuse me early screens
or the the single express systems
and and clinical trial
wonderful thank you don for that answer
okay
so we'll move on to our next question
we've gotten so many good questions and
thank you so much to the audience for
all of these questions um
let's look for our next one
okay what about okay here's one
there's a small variation in the
clinical comparison with the chip
is it within the error limits of the
measurements or do we need
further improvement in the model
yep so this is done so we would always
be looking to to improve upon the model
itself but in
in this case in terms of the variation
that we see we do believe that's within
the
the biology of the system um and and
what we would expect to see within just
the natural laboratory
experimental error that you would have
in in any sort of biological system and
testing
thank you so much john now our next
question do you have any data on
megalin or cubulin i'll take this
question
yes we have the data about expression
and functionality
in terms of functionality we measured
albumin opaque
and we could see increased uptake in the
chip compared to steady culture
also when we correlated our uh the belt
the data from the chip to in vivo it was
within physiological development range
thank you kj so our next one do you and
i think this one is for you as well do
you plan to create a kidney d
excuse me a kidney disease relevant
models on the chip
yes it is possible to build different
types of disease models for kidney
uh as i briefly mentioned uh there are
different ways
of making disease states for the renal
model
one is utilizing patient drive style
cell
so one example we did was creating a
diabetic
uh diabetic uh kidney model by utilizing
the cell proxima tubular cells from
a type two diabetes outpatient so that
was one
um proof-of-concept type of study that
we did
we could see maintenance of phenotype of
that patient
maintained in the chip over time and
when we test
when we tested therapeutics we could see
efficacy as well
so same approach can go with other
disease
model type as well so if you maybe uh
leave your uh contact information we can
provide additional detail
thank you kj for that okay
so moving on to our next question
[Music]
what about
[Music]
okay let's go to okay here's one for you
can we use organoids for the kidney chip
model
i can take the technician as well uh yes
we can do that
so far we have been utilizing organoids
for multiple different organ models
including intestine
and it is possible for for other organ
models including kidney
so the way we've been doing is utilizing
organoids and we expand them
and then before putting the organoid in
the chip we uh
fragment them in smaller size so we
create a monoculture monolayer
first and then we differentiate them in
the chip underflow and additional
mechanical forces
so the benefit of still culturing
organoid in the chip is having
uh vesicular uh compartment allowing
really uh
additional really cellular interaction
uh between
different cell types so similar approach
can be done
for the kidney and the other component
that we could a little bit
optimize or test differently is
putting different sizes or different
methods of
fragmentation when we add organoid in
the chip
and we can also utilize the top chainer
by
adding different types of or thickness
of the gel
so yeah it is possible with different
many different ways
wonderful thank you so much so now our
next question
in the future would you develop chips
that incorporate proximal tubule
cells from different populations for
example
different ethnicities or male or female
so this is diamond that's a great
question because of the fact that we do
know not only within
the ethnicities but then also
age-related
and we could even look at at the
potential of
cells from diseased patients so so yes
because this is a cell culture model we
can
you know as long as we can obtain the
cells and make certain that they are
well characterized and that the system
itself is well characterized
we could basically introduce those to be
able to
to populate the the kidney side
or the kidney channel i should say with
various models
so but the biggest thing there is is
making certain that the system is well
characterized so that we have we have
faith in the results that are coming
forward
thank you don now our next looks like
we've got time for maybe one or two more
questions so
our next one is can you see the chips
with different cell types
like primary culture proximal tubules
yes uh i will take this question uh yes
we can do that
um the current proxy material kidney
chip model we have
is based on primary cell sources and uh
coke culture
both having endo and ep both are from
primary sources of healthy human
so that's baseline of the model in case
we have other sources of the cells
available
we can certainly use other cell types as
well
wonderful thank you so much kj so it
looks like we've got time
for one more question let's go ahead and
look for r
let's go ahead and look for our last
question
we want to thank the audience again for
these amazing questions that have come
in today
okay our last question
where do you source your epithelial and
endothelial cells from
yes uh i'll take this question uh it is
commercially available
their sources both renal epithelial and
endothelial cells and it's part of our
product
a kidney bio kit so we provide a
qualified two seed
cell sources both epithelium and
endothelium from commercial resources
wonderful kj thank you so much for that
and we want to thank
dr anna thank you again to dr anderson
dr zhang and dr mckenzie
do any of you have any final comments
for our audience
again i'd like to uh you know thank the
audience for attending
um some great questions coming through
here and and those that we weren't able
to get to live we'll definitely follow
up with uh
with email answers and so on and again
you know
looking forward to developing
partnerships and and taking this
this model forward to to help actually
bring bring new compounds to the market
and
and address many of the the unmet
medical needs that are out there
patients are patients are waiting um and
you know we can't we can't uh
we can't slow down the discovery process
i second that thank you so much everyone
for your time and great uh
questions and interaction thank you
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank you dr
anderson dr
jiang and dr mckenzie for their time
today and their important research
we would also like to thank lappert and
our sponsor emulate
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
labrets will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now thank you so much for
joining us
and until next time bye bye everyone